Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Image and color editing is an actively researched
topic with really cool applications that you
will see in a second. Most of the existing
solutions are either easy to use but lack
in expressiveness, or they are expressive,
but too complex for novices to use. Computation
time is also an issue as some of the operations
in Photoshop can take more than a minute to
carry out.
For color editing, the workflow is very simple,
the program extracts the dominant colors of
an image, which we can interactively edit
ourselves.
An example use case would be recoloring the
girl's blue sweater to turquoise, or changing
the overall tone of the image to orange. Existing
tools that can do this are usually either
too slow or only accessible to adept users.
It is also important to note that it is quite easy
to take these great results for granted. Using
a naive color transfer technique would destroy
a sizeable part of the dynamic range of the
image, and hence, legitimate features which
are all preserved if we use this algorithm
instead.
One can also use masks to selectively edit
different parts of the image.
The technique executes really quickly, opening
up the possibility of not real time, but interactive
recoloring of animated sequences.
Or, you can also leverage the efficiency of
the method to edit not one, but a collection
of images in one go.
The paper contains a rigorous evaluation against
existing techniques. For instance, they show
that this method executed three to twenty
times faster than the one implemented in Adobe
Photoshop.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!